I think everything they argue in terms
of you know advocating for no choice and
and advocating for open borders type
policies and stuff whatever your opinion
is let's give you mine you have you have
these people who first of all they claim
to represent marginalized voices but
like you just said no they have the
wealth and the means they can do
whatever they want these people are now
being restricted
they also advocate for programs that say
Harvard where they're like Harvard is
now allowed to discriminate against
people based on race but they're the
ones claiming to be protecting
marginalized voices they they're Pro
monopolies they're in favor of the
private businessman what they want they
want government control these things
they're it's it's completely
hypocritical and I don't know if you've
seen in Connecticut there was actually a
a course that was take a quart case that
was taken up by Pacific Legal Foundation
in Connecticut they have something
called magnet schools which are
government-run schools that you can
choose I went to a magnet school in
Texas growing up and I've benefited from
it but they had a rule in place in one
of their big cities in Connecticut and
it was that you had to have some certain
percentage of whites and ages in your
school had to be 25% white plus Asians I
don't know why you know why do
minorities need whites and Asians to do
good job that just seems ridiculous on
its basis to me but what was happening
in these cities was that charter schools
tend to benefit the racial minorities
that and we've seen this all across the
United States are more likely to use
these so they were getting up on that
seventy five percent threshold and in
the law it actually said even if you
have open seats if a you know if a
racial minority tries to come into the
school and you're at that seventy five
percent threshold you they're not
allowed to go into the school because
then you won't have that twenty five
percent white plus Asian maximum so
that's that's like explicit
discrimination by race by a
government-run school in Connecticut so
the courts at the state level I believe
ruled against that you know that the
admission policy so that's that's no
good anymore well but they're also now
fighting it at the state level overall
in Connecticut so it's still a legal
battle that's ongoing didn't AOC get her
you know there's like one of the fears
that came out recently yes so this this
New York Post I think
first it was that they did a series of
the AOC tapes on near post like a week
or two ago and these videos were about
you know from like 2017 but they found a
video where she's walking through New
York City I don't remember what
neighborhood it was but she said oh you
know yada yada
by the way down the street from here I
got my goddaughter into a charter school
and so this is again kind of sneaking up
on this hypocrisy idea where look she
obviously hurt she obviously thought a
charter school was a good opportunity
for her goddaughter if she got her into
one I don't know what she actually meant
by getting her into one maybe she helped
her fill out the application and stuff
because it's supposed to be a surprise
moderate so she supports it privately
but then publicly she comes out on
social media supporting the LA teacher
strike and opposing privatization and
during the Li la teacher strike and I
think January of this of 2019 they were
opposing charter schools and so it
wasn't that they were opposing voucher
programs in LA they were they don't even
have a voucher program in LA they were
opposing the public charter schools in
LA so she was endorsing this strike that
was you know fighting against the type
of school that she helped her
goddaughter get into and right obviously
supported if she is she on your list of
hypocrites she's not because look this
wasn't this wasn't her kid this was her
goddaughter we try to make it you know
we try to restrict ourselves as much as
possible to make it clear cases of
hypocrisy on this map so I mean there's
not a lot of evidence on this and
there's not a lot of evidence that AOC
has come out hard against school choice
so she's mostly been silent on it but
she did say you know she did support you
know anti privatization efforts and
which meant anti charter efforts in LA
and then she was on The Breakfast Club
in an interview make me a couple weeks
ago she got like two big airs in that
interview she called Bloomberg former
president she was like oh yeah when blue
Berg was president she means mayor yeah
and then wives okay five seconds later
she said oh yeah you know charter
schools in New York City they started in
the 1970s that wasn't actually true the
first charter school in the United
States wasn't until 1992 in Minnesota
look but you know during the interview
she did say that
you know back then it was okay because
they are more community-based charter
schools now they're all corporate and
now I don't like them but in 2017 she
helped her goddaughter get it right one
well yeah hypocrisy and you know what
I'm gonna say it cuz I said this on
Twitter
AOC is what happens when you take
someone who thinks they're really really
smart and give them political power and
so I'm like look man this is why I'm not
gonna run for office cuz I don't want to
I don't know what I don't want to be
that like I don't like I can be dumb you
can you can call me names the knowledge
bag alright ma'am to my mount business
well look there's a there's a better way
of handling these issues so like during
that Breakfast Club interview she didn't
have to pretend like she knew that
charter schools started in 1970 she
could have just said you know back when
charter school started right she didn't
act like she knew the specific date and
it's okay you know like it if you're a
political candidate at that high of a
level you know you have a lot of
different issues that you're focusing on
so I get it if you don't understand
school choice as well as I would support
as well as I would understand school
choice because that's the only thing I
focus on but like don't come out and say
like I know all these minor details when
you don't but I think her whole thing is
is it's as long as you're morally right
right yeah yeah no matter if you get the
facts right as long as you're morally
said some people are more more concerned
about being factually right instead of
morally right and I'm like dude what is
your more you worry right yeah we'll
income kids to be able to pick their
schools that's not morally right well
it's not active I don't think she
actually has principles to be honest I
think you know do they want to give like
when they when they release the fa Q's
with a green new deal and it said people
who are unable or unwilling to work they
remove that well which is it which do
you support do you support universal
income guarantees and what we like what
we heard from her her former advisor
saikat he said it wasn't about the
environment it was about transforming
the economy jobs yeah we're gonna create
a bunch of government jobs it was about
socialism I mean the whole thing was
like a mishmash and I've been talked to
some lefties about it who are like it
sounds like a great great idea I could
you read it did you raid the
identitarian weird stuff about racial
pay equity like what is that through the
environment dude well and didn't she
like explicitly say these are gonna be
Union jobs probably I don't know I think
it's maybe not written in stone but I
think she said we're gonna have good
union jobs or maybe that was another
well so here's the thing it's like do
you care about the environment because
if that was true you'd be you'd be
embracing nuclear power ya know that
they're probably opposed to it do you
you wouldn't be creating an economic
policy manifesto called the green New
Deal while arguing it's about saving the
world from climate change well another
thing is we don't know what the net
benefits or costs are of climate change
our David Freeman Milton Friedman's son
did a whole nice talk on this where he's
like yeah I mean we know that the world
is getting a little warmer but we don't
know like what the net effect of that is
there are some you know negative effects
of people having to move rich people
having to move away from the rich people
but you know there are some benefits
like there's more usable land in Canada
for example so that's a benefit but no
one can really determine the net costs
or benefit of global warming and we
don't know what the perfect temperature
is someone like places like London
getting a little bit warmers actually a
little bit of a good thing so yeah we
don't know I think everybody kind of
agrees that the world is getting a
little warmer but where we disagree is
like what should we do about it and how
much are humans actually contributing I
think I think the answer is simple what
if we go into another Ice Age for
example yeah aren't we do for another
Ice Age that commit warming could slowly
be a good thing if that's the case
you've got you know you've got some
people who say that it's not happening
that's rare you've got some people say
it's happening but it's not man-made I
think if the left that says
humanity is doing this and it's gonna
cause the end of the world 12 years to
varying degrees twelve eight I think
reddit soon Berg said eight years but
but to be fair they said something like
we have eight years to solve it or the
earth will be reparable damaged or
something like that so never turn them
back but like every time these types of
12 years statements or predictions are
made we always get to that point and
then nothing actually happened it keeps
happening
doomsday just there never never actually
comes they say we're frogs boiling in a
pot but we've been boiling since the 70s
and every prediction they've made has
failed so at a certain point you've
cried wolf and people don't care anymore
but I have a simple solution it's it's
you know one of the problems I see with
people like aoc and people on the left
is they don't try to actually
communicate with to the values of a
conservative or a moderate they go they
just go around screaming you know the
climate the planet is warming it's man's
fault do as I say or else we need
socialism okay well hold on first of all
I don't think she actually cares I
really don't like red
toon burg she apparently wrote an op-ed
saying like we need to end patriarchy
and colonialism I'm like what are you
talking has nothing to do with climate
change cuz they don't cares they
specialize into the climate stuff well
they're just using it as as you know an
inroad but the solution is simple that's
called technology it's it we shouldn't
be like when they advocate for shutting
down fossil fuels you know what it is
man it's it's this whole what I've
noticed right now of the whole left
versus right the left has been negative
on everything everything they propose is
a negative stop this stop that restrict
this take this and then you look at
Trump and Trump's like make it great
make more money make more jobs get
better trade deals and it's all about
boosting and making more if you if you
have a policy position that's like
here's my pitch so so I'll give you a
better example I think I think climate
change is a problem I defer to the
scientists I'm not the expert I'll tell
you what the solution is to create more
solutions technology advancement
progress net positive results what can
we do as a society to alleviate the
problems of carbon emissions if that's
what you're concerned about great it's
renewable technology it's nuclear energy
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you